alright I'm gonna go to the airport and
pick up uncle Seymour who's that he's
dad's grand uncle he's got one leg
Seymour this is not your port wheelchair
and I'm actually gonna need it back
Oh someone needs it more than this guy
okay got a big one dr. see another day
another life okay I hope everybody likes
the hotel you having a wedding at a
quality lunch toaster for slice the two
diamonds
this bad boy is gonna light up the
dessert table where's the magician I
never hit my children one of the good
things about not being there
you said to call the bills any problem
the leak spreading if the rest of the
place booked it's fine for a couple
hours but not a whole night no it's good
in moderation it's fine
we did you think give $0.99 wedding and
the booze bottles for Giants
let me bail us out at it every father
looks forward to making a wedding for
their little girl I have been able to
help my kids their entire lives in this
one
there's gotta be a decent hotel like a
boy I thought we talked about this - I
can handle it we get the call we can
cancel that oh yeah oh so like that I do
a little okay big smiles you guys get it
together okay yeah just give me one more
Drive
[Music]
you